und jetzt das heute
journal guten Abend die Appelle der
internationalen Gemeinschaft werden
drängender und verzweifelter das
Internationale Komitee vom Roten Kreuz
achtet generell sehr auf vorsichtige
Wortwahl jetzt heißt es aus Genf das
menschliche Leiden in Gaza ist
schockierend tausende getötet
Krankenhäuser kurz vor dem Kollaps es
werde Jahre dauern bis die zerstörte
Infrastruktur und Wohnhäuser wieder
aufgebaut sein uniceef das
Kinderhilfswerk der Vereinten Nationen
sagt Zitat Gaza ist ein Friedhof für
Kinder geworden und der UNO
Generalsekretär nennt die
Hilfslieferungen nach Gaza komplett
unzureichend die Operation der
israelischen Armee nach dem Hamas
Terrorangriff auf Israel geht weiter
Israel macht klar sie wird weitergehen
lü
walpot die Detonationen so berichten
Anwohner waren gewaltig am späten
Nachmittag nahm Israels Luftwaffe
mehrere Ziele im dicht besesiedelten
Flüchtlingslager jabalia in Gaza Stadt
unterbeschuss in den wohlblöcken so ein
israelischer Armeesprecher hätten sich
Hamas Kommandeure
verschanzt wir haben doch den
hamasführer von nordgaza Ibrahim biari
getötet die Bevölkerung ist diesen
Terroristen egal sie haben ihre
Infrastruktur gezielt unter solchen
Wohnhäusern
errichtet füllten Krankenhäuser in Gaza
sprechen von mindestens 50 Toten bei dem
Angriff und über 150
verletzten wir wissen nicht wohin mit
all den Verwundeten Kinder alte
Sterbende und Helfer bringen ständig
neue
Patienten wie viele Bewohner sich noch
im Kampfgebiet rund um gazastadt
aufhalten ist unklar aber die
Auswirkungen auf die Zivilbevölkerung
sind offensichtlich die Vereinten
Nationen warnen vor katastrophalen
Zuständen
Berichten zufolge sind mehr als
3450 Kinder getötet worden
erschütternderweise steigt diese Zahl
täglich Gaza ist zu einem Friedhof für
Kinder
geworden eine Feuerpause komme nicht den
Frage das unterstrich Israels
Regierungschef Netanyahu gestern die
Gefahr die von Hamas Terroristen ausgehe
müsse beseitigt werden Hamas
veröffentlichte heute diese Bilder sie
sollen Hamas Kämpfer im Gefecht mit
israelischen Truppen nördlich von Gaza
Stadtzeichen Israels Militär hält mit
eigenen Bildern dagegen die sollen
bestätigen dass israelische Truppen
immer tiefer in den Gazastreifen
vordringen am Abend tauchte in sozialen
Medien ein propagandavideo eines
hamassprechers auf darin kündigt er die
Freilassung ausländischer Geiseln für
die kommenden Tage an unterdessen gab es
auch heute wieder in Israel Luftalarm
und Einschläge wie hier in asstot
verletzt wurde niemand bringen wir
unseren Israel korespondentench noch mit
dazu Michael beverunge live in Tel Aviv
guten Abend Michael wir haben ihn gerade
gesehen diesen sogenannten Sprecher der
Hamas der die Freilassung ausländischer
Geiseln in den kommenden Tagen ankündigt
was ist davon zu
halten na ja das ist erstmal das Gebaren
terroristischer Kidnapper die sich
versuchen einen humanitären Anstrich zu
geben äh eine ähnliche Ankündigung gab
es schon vor ein paar Tagen es ist
nichts herausgefolgt und ist natürlich
der Versuch die wie wir gesehen haben
doch immer stärker werdende militärische
Offensive die Bodenoffensive in Gaza der
Israelis zu konterkarieren
hier in Israel hat das wenig Eindruck
hinterlassen die Regierung wir haben es
gehört ist fest entschlossen netanyaho
hat noch mal deutlich bekräftigt es wird
aus seiner Sicht keinen Waffenstillstand
geben jetzt und nicht auch später bevor
die Hamas zerschlagen ist und das kann
man natürlich sehen als Worte eines
angeschlagenen Regierungschef der
versucht seine Reputation
wiederherzustellen aber ich denke auch
ein großer Teil des
sicherheitsestablishments und auch der
Bevölkerung stützt diesen Kurs
letztendlich auch wenn die Gefangenen
befrei die Geiselbefreiung durch
Verhandlung oder andere Möglichkeiten
dadurch eher eingeschränkt wird Michael
vielen Dank für diese Analyse aus
Israel jetzt nach Deutschland und zu
einem Ehen Prinzip dass alle die hier
mal Jura studiert haben auswendig können
ne bis idem oder
allgemeinverständlich niemand kann wegen
derselben Tat zweimal vor Gericht
gestellt werden so verbietet es auch das
Grundgesetz und dennoch trat Ende 2021
eine Reform der Strafprozessordnung in
Kraft danach ging das eben doch bei
schwersten Verbrechen wenn es etwa neue
Beweismittel
gibt alles wieder zurück sagt aber heute
das Bundesverfassungsgericht nebis in
idem gilt weiter und zwar ohne
einschränk die Details von Christop
Schneider als am Vormittag nach gut Z
Stunden die mündliche Urteilsbegründung
endet fast die Vizepräsidentin zusammen
sie sehen die Entscheidung ist uns nicht
leicht gefallen sie ist auch nicht
einstimmig gefallen im Ergebnis aber ist
sie klar es geht um den Fall der
Frederike von Möhlmann 1981 wird die
17-jährige vergewaltigt und ermordet in
einem Wald bei Zelle der mutmaßliche
Täter Ismet h wird aus Mangel an
Beweisen freigesprochen 31 Jahre später
gibt eine DNA-Analyse dass er wohl doch
der Mörder ist doch eine neuerliche
Anklage nicht möglich denn nach dem
Grundgesetz darf man nicht mehrmals
wegen derselben Sache angeklagt werden
trotzdem wird 2021 von der großen
Koalition ein umstrittenes Gesetz
erlassen das eine Wiederaufnahme zu
Ungunsten eines verurteilten zulässt
wenn neue Tatsachen und Beweismittel
beigebracht werden das
Bundesverfassungsgericht erklärt diese
Gesetzesänderung nun für
verfassungswidrig damit ist die
Verfassungsbeschwerde von ISM
erfolgreich entscheidend Artikel 103
Absatz 3 Grundgesetz bestimmt niemand
darf wegen derselben Tat mehrmals
bestraft werden ein unumstößliches
Prinzip nur schwererträglich für die
Familie
Müllmann das ist kein Tag der
Gerechtigkeit weder für die Familie von
mümer noch für viele von uns wo wir
drauf gehofft haben dass jemand wegen
eines falschen Freispruchs doch noch
überführt werden kann trotzdem die
rechts hat Vorrang vor einer möglichen
neuen Strafverfolgung ein Urteil des
höchsten deutschen Gerichts des
Rechtsgeschichte
schreibt so weitere Kurznachrichten in
dieser kurzen Sendung jetzt in der
Übersicht die hast du Hanna gut drei
Wochen nach der Landtagswahl ist Markus
Söder vom Bayerischen Landtag erneut zum
Ministerpräsidenten gewählt worden er
erhielt 120 der 198 abgegebenen Stimmen
wegen der stabilen Mehrheit von CSU und
Freien Wählern war die Neuwahl eine
Formalie im Landtag anwesend war auch
der gestern vorübergehend festgenommene
AFD Abgeordnete halemba gegen den
22jährigen wird unter anderem wegen des
Verdachts der Volksverhetzung
ermittelt wenige Tage vor dem
bundländertreffen zur Migration hat
nordrennwestfalens Ministerpräsident
wüst für die Abwicklung von
Asylverfahren außerhalb der EU plädiert
auch der Fraktionschef der FDP im
Bundestag dür sprach sich in der
Süddeutschen Zeitung dafür aus
Bundeskanzler Scholz äußerte sich
dagegen zurückhaltend genauso wie
Innenministerin fäser die die aktuell
geplanten migrationsabkommen als
zielführender
bezeichnete Bundeswirtschaftsminister
habbeck hat sich erneut für einen
vergünstigten industriestrompreis
ausgesprochen und eine schnelle
Entscheidung dazu gefordert auf einer
industriekonferenz warnte habbeck vor
der Abwanderung von Unternehmen auch der
Bundesverband der deutschen Industrie
und die IG Teil unterstrichen die
Forderung die FDP ist gegen harbcks
Vorschlag eines verbilligten
industriestrompreises und auch
Bundeskanzler Scholz sieht diesen
skeptisch zu den Wetteraussichten morgen
am Vormittag in nordseen Nähe am
Nachmittag ganz im Westen Regen sonst
wolkig im Südosten auch länger sonnig
Höchstwerte zwischen 9 und 17°. am
Donnerstag im Westen Regen und
sturmböhen im Osten länger freundlich
Freitag sehr wechselhaft und kühler
Samstag erneut
stürmisch ja und das war's von uns wir
wünschen Ihnen jetzt noch viel Spaß beim
fluball dem schließen wir uns alle hier
an und sagen tschüss bis morgen
[Musik]
tschüss